we have exclusive new details tonight
about former FBI agent Peter Struck's
lawsuit over his firing the career agent
emphasis infamously sent a number of
anti-trump texts to his girl friend and
lover Lisa Paige during the Russia
investigation and was ultimately let go
last week struck filed the lawsuit
claiming he was fired quote as the
result of unrelenting pressure from
President Trump and his political allies
in Congress in the media which included
quote constant tweets in other
disparaging statements by the President
as well as direct appeals from the
president and then Attorney General
Jefferson Jefferson Sessions and FBI
director Christopher Rea joining me now
is trey Gowdy former Chairman's
second-best chairman of the House
Oversight Committee and Fox News
contributor I had the pleasure and honor
and serving with mr. Gowdy throughout my
time in Congress and I like the
spectacles that you've got going on here
we're expecting something dramatic with
your hair or your suit but I love the
glasses I'm glad that you could join us
here tonight Nick
Mulvaney told me glasses make you look
smarter but I don't think it's worked
for either one of us no it certainly
didn't work for Victor Nick Mulvaney's
so Trey thank you so much for joining us
here what you've got you're one of the
few people you and John Radcliffe the
congressman out of Texas who have
actually read the unredacted versions of
the so-called 302s and the FISA
applications at whatnot you have mr.
struck here who's claiming he was fired
because you know the president was
tweeting about him but what's the
reality about how and why he was fired
well there two things remember he says
he was fired because he was exercising
his constitutionally protected right to
free speech by Jason he also offered to
accept a 60-day demotion he offered to
take a cut in pay and he expressed
profound remorse so you don't express
profound remorse for exercising a
constitutionally protected right and you
don't agree to a 60-day suspension and a
cut and pay and a demotion if he ain't
done nothing wrong so
that's what he did who fired him it
wasn't any of the people he sued
ironically enough it was the deputy
director of the FBI again a guy named
David Bowdich but wouldn't Chris Rea it
was David voltage let me tell you he's a
career FBI guy he's not a political
appointee let me give you a little
flavor of his background he was a local
cop then he became a bureau agent he was
a SWAT team guy and this is what he did
when he was in the bureau he
investigated street gangs in Los Angeles
like the Bloods and the Crips he
investigated Mexican drug cartels and a
group called Hells Angels not Charlie's
Angels Hells Angels so I don't think a
god that's done that for his entire
career in law enforcement it's going to
be intimidated by a tweet or two from
anybody and that's who made the decision
of fire struck no that's interesting now
these were actually found on strux
government-issued phones correct and as
you recall it was Michael Horowitz who
was the inspector general who had to
engage the Pentagon to develop the
algorithm because the FBI said they
couldn't read they'd find these texts
but sure enough they went to the
Pentagon developed algorithm and then we
magically did get the text yeah I think
Horowitz found some of them and then
there was a gap where it was missing and
he was trying to close the gap I
Horowitz has done a fantastic job and I
see with them with the suicide of
Jeffrey Epstein or the apparent suicide
he's got more work on his hands since I
was a Federal Bureau of Prisons so
Horowitz is a straight shooter but he
did find him he deserves a lot of credit
for that because if it weren't for
Horowitz we would never know the person
leading in the Russia investigation had
a historic level of animus towards the
person he claimed to be dispassionately
investigating no no it truly is amazing
I want to move on to Bruce or I find it
fascinating his title here I I don't
understand this
he was the associate Deputy Attorney
General and director of the Department
of Justice organized crime and Drug
Enforcement Task Force that's his title
and you go to death yeah osa def is the
acronym here but why would he be
involved and engaged and even
any proximity to Trump Russia and the
probe that Muller was I mean it just
makes no sense though I don't know let
me think could it it couldn't be because
his wife was working for fusion cheap
huh oh yeah that's right I forgot that
wouldn't be it would it yeah maybe that
was that Jason I read those 302s well
over a year ago I might have been the
first person in house to read them when
Devon sent me over there I'm just as
stunned I used to work for the
Department of Justice I hold it in very
high regard but you have an FBI source
who was defrocked he was let go because
he couldn't follow the rules and then oh
by the way he said he was desperate to
keep Donald Trump from becoming
president that's the FBI source they got
rid of him they can be legitimately so
that's behind stealing conduit of
information yeah that's Christopher
still so steal he can't talk to the
bureau anymore so then he talks to a
senior level DOJ official and he's
running his information through a
prosecutor it is unheard of I mean hey
first of all imagine a local cop who was
or a local informant or source who was
let go because they're biased and
because they can't follow the rules you
wouldn't want them on any kind of case
much less than investigation like this
but Bruce or carry this information to
DOJ put himself in the chain of custody
which is also unheard of for a
prosecutor I'm stunned when I read the
articles but I knew about it a year ago
so I guess my level of stuntman has
dissipated song so it remember Nellie or
is one of less than 20 employees over at
fusion GPS and this proximity between
Nellie our and Bruce or and with the
defrocked as you said Steele who was
discredited remember it was the FBI that
said you can no longer do business with
mr. Steele but the timeline is such that
they continue to do business together
correct right but why why he wouldn't
follow the rules they didn't even follow
the FBI's own rules so they have a
source that they can't keep as a source
because he can't do the handful of
things they said hey you got to do or
don't do in this case can't talk to the
media but he did it anyway the
punishment is you're no longer a source
the punishment is not you get to get
your information
to DOJ another way it just doesn't work
that way not supposed to yeah
real quickly Jerry Nadler has caused a
lot of confusion on a lot of fronts
pretty much everything he's involved
with but the idea is is this impeachment
or is it not impeachment is it informal
impeachment or formal impeachment what
is it I think it means you wear a tuxedo
instead of a Hawaiian shirt if it's if
it's formal I have no idea with that me
I mean what is informal impeachment look
Jerry Jerry's on a tough spot you got
some really charismatic New York
politicians Alexandria Hakeem Kathleen
Rice he just ain't one of them and he's
gonna be in trouble next election cycle
so he's trying to gin up the base but
here's my advice here either file
articles of impeachment put them on the
floor of the house for a vote or shut up
but nobody is falling for this in formal
versus formal impeachment damn but one
kind go file your articles of
impeachment put them on the floor you'll
win in the house you'll lose in front of
the jury but go ahead and do it but
there's no such thing as informal
impeachment I love that just don't wear
a tie you'll be it's informal
impeachment or tails or gloves
yes congressman thank you so much one of
America's best daddy we appreciate you
being here